Salut, moi, c'est Guillaume Hachez. Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec. Ravi de vous retrouver cette semaine pour un nouvel épisode.
Vous êtes très nombreux à avoir découvert Septante Minutes Avec suite au passage de Florence Hainaut et Marie Peltier dans l'émission.
Je remercie toutes celles et ceux qui ont relayé l'épisode sur les réseaux sociaux puisque c'est en partie ça qui m'a permis d'entrer en contact avec mon invité de cette semaine après qu'il ait lui-même écouté l'épisode précédent.
J'ai eu le plaisir de rejoindre François Gemenne dans le bureau de la chaîne LN24 pour discuter ensemble des sujets qui sont les siens, à savoir la politique migratoire européenne, les idées reçues quant à l'immigration,
les réfugiés climatiques ou encore la xénophobie.
François est belge, mais vit à Paris puisqu'il est professeur à Sciences Po. Raison pour laquelle vous l'entendrez souvent parler de la France tout au long de cet épisode.
D'où vient la xénophobie ? Est-ce que fermer les frontières permettrait vraiment de réguler la migration ? Pourquoi y a-t-il en Europe si peu de différences en termes de politique migratoire entre l'extrême droite et la gauche sociale-démocrate ?
Réponse dans cet épisode. C'est parti. J'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir d'être avec François Gemenne. Bonjour François.
Bonjour Guillaume.
François, tu es politologue, professeur à l'Université de Liège et à Sciences Po,
membre du Giec ainsi que directeur de l'Observatoire Hugo à l'Université de Liège, qui étudie les interactions entre les impacts sur l'environnement, la migration humaine et la sphère politique.
Est-ce que j'ai oublié quelque chose ?
Des détails de la vie personnelle. Je suis le papa de deux petits garçons, des choses comme ça.
Oui, j'aurais aussi pu dire que tu apparais régulièrement sur le plateau de la RTBF et chez LN24. Tu publies également un livre, dans une semaine, qui se nomme « On a tous un ami noir », publié chez Fayard à Paris.
Voilà, c'est des choses que les académiques font, écrire des livres-
Bah oui, mais justement, j'allais te demander-
Ça fait partie du métier.
...comment est-ce que tu trouves le temps de faire tout ça ?
Ça, ça demande de l'organisation, en fait. Ça demande de compartimenter, de minuter beaucoup la journée. Et donc c'est vrai que j'ai le problème d'être toujours en retard.
On commence cet entretien en retard, on va pas mentir-
Joli start en effet.
...aux auditeurs. Mais c'est vrai que ça demande effectivement d'aborder chaque journée comme une sorte de sprint assez minuté.
Et ça permet de faire des choses assez différentes. Et c'est vrai que moi, si j'ai choisi
une carrière de chercheur, c'était précisément parce qu'aucune journée ne ressemblait à l'autre, que je pouvais pas décrire une journée type ou une semaine type.
Et c'est vrai que j'aime beaucoup cette variété des activités. Ça demande par contre pas mal d'organisation, surtout quand on a des enfants et surtout quand on ne travaille pas à l'endroit où on habite.
Oui, et donc pas mal d'organisation, pas mal d'énergie aussi. Tu ne tombes jamais à court, tu n'as jamais envie de prendre une journée de repos ?
Parce qu'on a l'impression que tu-
Journée de repos, non-
...tu bouges tout le temps.
...par contre, j'ai des moments où je suis plus déprimé ou parfois plus cynique, où je me demande quelle est au fond l'utilité de tout ça.
C'est un peu usant.
Ça a parfois
un côté un peu usant, ce sentiment parfois de prêcher dans le désert ou parfois, c'est vrai, quand on travaille sur des sujets qui sont parfois humainement difficiles,
non seulement le climat, mais surtout les migrations qui engendrent malheureusement
une série de drames et de tragédies, c'est vrai que parfois, ça a un côté un peu usant et déprimant.
Par contre, c'est vrai que j'ai jamais besoin d'une journée de repos. Je suis quelqu'un qui, en vacances, déteste être déconnecté.
Je déteste être loin de mon travail, loin de mes e-mails-
OK.
...parce que je vois pas du tout-
Tu es always on.
D'une certaine manière, oui. Et je vois pas du tout, quelque part, mon travail comme quelque chose qui me pèserait.
C'est vrai que je confonds mon travail et ma vie. Et donc, quelque part, être sans mon travail, sans mes recherches, c'est quelque chose qui me manque.
Et donc, en vacances, je dois parfois faire effectivement un peu l'effort de me déconnecter, mais c'est vrai que je n'aime pas du tout être loin de mon travail.
J'ai pas du tout ce besoin de déconnexion.
Tu l'as dit, tout se mélange un petit peu. Y a à la fois dans ta démarche de chercheur aussi une démarche politique, hein, clairement, une démarche militante.
Est-ce que le fait d'apparaître dans les médias en faveur des migrants, en faveur d'une politique migratoire plus accueillante, c'est quelque chose qui fait partie de ton travail ?
C'est en tout cas comme ça que je le conçois. J'imagine pas qu'on puisse, en tout cas, j'imagine pas que je puisse être chercheur et ne pas être impliqué dans les débats publics.
Pour moi, la question de l'implication et de l'engagement dans les débats publics est vraiment inhérente à la démarche du chercheur.
C'est-à-dire qu'on travaille sur des problèmes de société et qu'il faut qu'on puisse expliquer
aux gens sur quoi on travaille et en quoi la science peut enrichir, peut informer la décision politique et les grands choix collectifs que nous avons à faire.
Et donc, vraiment, je suis, je crois, à l'opposé du chercheur dans la tour d'ivoire. Pour moi, c'est vraiment très important d'être en prise et d'être en phase avec les débats de société.
Quelque chose qui m'énerve toujours, c'est quand parfois, on doit recruter de jeunes chercheurs et parfois, on repère des étudiants brillants à qui on propose de faire une thèse de doctorat
et qui disent : « Oui, mais je voudrais faire d'abord quelque chose de plus concret
avant de me lancer dans la recherche ou avant de me lancer dans une carrière académique » et donc qui souhaitent prendre du temps pour, comme ils le disent, faire quelque chose de plus concret.
Mais pour moi, y a rien de plus concret que la recherche. La façon la plus efficace de changer le monde, c'est avec les connaissances.
Et donc je vois vraiment mon activité de chercheur comme une activité en prise sur le monde et comme une des façons les plus efficaces de changer le monde.
Vraiment, je voudrais pas faire autre chose. Les gens s'imaginent toujours que les chercheurs sont dans leur laboratoire ou dans des bibliothèques et sont des sortes de moines contemplatifs.
Pour toute interview, dès qu'on doit faire une photo pour un journal, je refuse toujours
d'être pris en photo ou interviewé devant une bibliothèque parce que je trouve que ça renvoie une image catastrophique du chercheur, comme si le chercheur était isolé dans son bureau, déconnecté de la réalité.
Alors que l'essentiel du travail qu'on fait à l'Observatoire Hugo, c'est du travail sur le terrain, c'est avec les personnes qui sont déplacées, avec les personnes qui subissent de plein fouet les impacts du changement climatique.
On réfléchit avec les gouvernements, avec les ONG, à des manières d'améliorer les choses. On essaye de voir comment se mettent en place des programmes, comment on peut les évaluer pour les améliorer.
Et donc c'est un travail qui est vraiment très concret, très en prise avec le terrain.
Pour revenir au livre que tu publies dans une semaine, « On a tous un ami noir ». Donc dans ce livre, tu commences par attaquer une série d'idées reçues, voilà, au sujet des migrants.
Tu commences par expliquer qu'il y a plus de gauchers que d'immigrés en France, qui sont-
En Belgique aussi.
qui sont assez peu nombreux et rares à poser problème. Mais bref, tu t'attaques à une série d'idées comme ça, y compris, et ça, c'est intéressant, on peut se pencher là-dessus.
En fait, le fait de fermer les frontières ne sert à rien, tu expliques.
C'est pas que ça ne sert à rien, c'est que ça ne sert pas du tout les buts
qu'on pense que cela poursuit. Les gens ont encore une conception des frontières comme celle d'un instrument qui permettrait de réguler les flux migratoires à l'échelle mondiale.
Et donc les gens et les gouvernements, dans leur grande majorité, pas par cynisme ou par méconnaissance, continuent à présenter les frontières comme une sorte de variable d'ajustement des flux migratoires mondiaux.
En d'autres termes, comme si, si on ouvrait les frontières, ça déciderait les gens à venir d'un coup et comme si, à l'inverse, si on les fermait, ça arrêterait les flux migratoires.
Et le problème, malheureusement, c'est que c'est méconnaître profondément les réalités des migrations, les ressorts profonds de ce qui décide les gens à migrer que d'imaginer que c'est une frontière ouverte qui va les faire migrer.
Les gens migrent souvent parce qu'ils en ont un besoin impérieux, parce qu'il s'agit de sauver leur vie, parce qu'il s'agit de nourrir leur famille ou parce qu'il s'agit tout simplement de réaliser le projet de toute une vie.
Et donc c'est pas une frontière ouverte qui va les décider à partir, qui va les décider à quitter leur famille, à sacrifier des milliers d'euros, à prendre tous les risques et parfois même à risquer leur propre vie.
Et c'est pas non plus une frontière fermée qui va les arrêter, parce qu'en réalité, ils seront prêts à tenter dix fois, cent fois, mille fois la traversée jusqu'à y réussir.
Et ils savent qu'à un moment donné, ils passeront. Et le seul moyen vraiment de garder une frontière hermétiquement fermée, c'est de tirer sur les gens qui essaient de passer, comme l'Allemagne le faisait au moment du mur de Berlin.
Mais sinon, il est impossible de garder une frontière hermétiquement fermée.
Et donc en réalité, quand on veut fermer les frontières, c'est surtout un message qu'on va envoyer à ceux qui sont à l'intérieur de la frontière plutôt qu'à ceux qui sont à l'extérieur.
C'est une manière de rassurer ceux qui sont à l'intérieur de la frontière sur leur identité collective, de leur dire : « Rassurez-vous, vous êtes du bon côté de la frontière », parce qu'il y a toujours un bon et un mauvais côté dans une frontière.
Et donc quand on va construire des murs ou des clôtures, ça va pas servir à empêcher les gens de venir. Ça va servir surtout à produire des images de télévision, des photos de presse-
...à en quelque sorte matérialiser la démarcation entre nous et eux. Et aujourd'hui, de plus en plus, les frontières et quelque part notre identité collective vont se construire en excluant des groupes plutôt qu'en les incluant.
Et je crois que ça doit tous effectivement nous inquiéter. Et donc les frontières ne sont pas du tout une variable d'ajustement ou de contrôle des flux migratoires mondiaux, pardon,
mais vont surtout être des messages politiques adressés à ceux qui sont à l'intérieur.
Donc le fait de fermer les frontières, tu l'expliques, est à la fois une
décision qui est très juteuse vis-à-vis du marché des frontières, comme tu le décris, donc, soit l'achat de matériel, l'achat de drones, tous les contracteurs qu'on peut employer aux frontières,
que au niveau politique, donc ça, tu viens de l'expliquer, y a finalement une espèce de construction de récit autour des frontières pour se rassurer, pour nous expliquer qu'on est envié, on est du bon côté de la frontière.
Et donc le mur de Trump, finalement, incarne assez bien ça. Est-ce que c'est-
C'est aussi le mur de Trump, c'est une façon de diviser son électorat, c'est une façon de créer des polémiques dans la population.
Et donc c'est aussi une façon pour lui de gagner des électeurs. C'est l'application du principe de Machiavel : diviser pour régner, créer la polémique pour s'attirer des électeurs.
Et donc il faut pas s'y méprendre, il y a des bénéficiaires à ce renforcement des frontières. Il y a des bénéfices politiques que peuvent en tirer les nationalistes.
Il y a aussi des bénéfices financiers qu'en tirent les industries de l'armement et de la surveillance. C'est un très juteux business.
Et puis bien sûr, il y a les bénéfices des passeurs. Plus on va fermer les frontières, plus on va entretenir le business des passeurs.
Parce que forcément, plus la frontière sera fermée, plus les gens qui ont absolument besoin de la franchir auront besoin d'aide extérieure.
Et donc, de ce fait, nous sommes complices des passeurs. Et le principal effet de la fermeture des frontières, c'est pas d'empêcher les migrations, c'est de les rendre plus coûteuses, plus dangereuses et donc malheureusement plus meurtrières.
Et donc toujours dans ce contexte de cette construction de récit,
tu expliques que 61 % des Français sont persuadés que l'identité française est en train de disparaître, que, je crois, un quart des Français croient à la théorie du grand remplacement.
Toutes ces choses-là, cette idée de « notre identité est en danger, on doit la protéger », etc.
En fait, ça me fait penser à une, et là, je passe du coq à l'âne, mais une affiche qui était publiée
pendant le confinement ici en Belgique, qui était publiée, je crois, par la NVA, et qui montrait le fait qu'« en Flandre, on va continuer l'école comme avant, même si les cours doivent reprendre pendant l'été.
Alors qu'en Wallonie, ils sont pas sûrs, ils veulent y aller lentement, il faut y aller doucement. »
Je suis assez campagne.
Et je me souviens que ton ami et collègue, Alain Gerlache, avait commenté en disant : « Finalement, le nationalisme, c'est un complexe d'infériorité non résolu.
» Est-ce que la xénophobie, de la même manière, là, je passe du coq à l'âne, hein, mais est-ce que la xénophobie, ce n'est pas aussi une espèce de complexe de supériorité non résolu
qui-- on a très envie de se croire bien au-dessus de toutes ces populations,
très souvent de couleur, très souvent qui viennent des blocs subsahariens, de Syrie ou autres.
On a très envie de se croire bien au-dessus, se croire privilégié et du coup, on fait cette construction de récit.
Ça touche effectivement à notre inconscient collectif-
...profond. Il y a des histoires qu'on va se raconter sur soi-même et sur notre identité collective.
La peur de l'immigration, elle est souvent liée à une peur de disparaître ou une peur d'être remplacé, une peur qui est largement
irrationnelle et qu'on pourra contrer tant qu'on veut par des chiffres ou par des faits, ça n'aura aucune prise parce qu'on touche ici à l'aspect irrationnel de nos sentiments.
Et donc il y a effectivement cette peur
et cette insécurité par rapport à notre identité collective. Et quelque part, la xénophobie révèle aussi cette sorte d'insécurité par
rapport à notre identité collective et cette difficulté à admettre que cette identité collective se transmet et se transforme sans cesse, y compris par l'arrivée de nouvelles personnes.
Et donc on continue souvent à la fantasmer dans une sorte de passé qu'on imagine glorieux ou meilleur qu'avant ou supérieur à avant.
Et c'est pour ça que le livre s'appelle « On a tous un ami noir » parce que c'est l'excuse par excellence qui est donnée par les racistes quand ils se défendent d'être racistes.
Mais fondamentalement, nous avons tous cela inscrit dans notre inconscient collectif, une certaine anxiété, une certaine peur par rapport à notre identité collective et quelque part, une peur
de voir cette identité collective se transformer et changer aussi au gré des flux migratoires, mais aussi au gré de la mondialisation ou d'autres transformations de nos sociétés.
On n'est jamais complètement déconstruit aujourd'hui. Toi, t'en es où par rapport à ça ? Est-ce que tu gardes encore un petit peu au fond de toi cette peur d'être remplacé ou bien est-ce que c'est complètement anéanti ?
C'est jamais complètement anéanti. Si on veut être honnête avec soi-même, on peut essayer de la rationaliser tant qu'on veut.
Effectivement, on a tous une certaine forme de peur ou d'angoisse par rapport à notre identité collective. On a tous ce fantasme par rapport à un passé un peu nostalgique.
On a tous une série de préjugés par rapport à l'étranger et y compris dans des domaines tout à fait simples de la vie.
Combien de fois est-ce que, par exemple, à des conférences ou à des colloques académiques, je n'ai pas eu des collègues étrangers qu'on
félicitait non pas pour la qualité de leur présentation, mais pour leur niveau de français ou pour le fait qu'ils parlaient sans accent, alors que c'était parfois des gens qui étaient nés et avaient grandi en France ou en Belgique.
On a toute une série de préjugés dans le sport. Moi-même, lorsque je regarde une course de fond aux Jeux olympiques, j'ai toujours tendance à imaginer que ce sont les athlètes noirs qui vont gagner plutôt que les athlètes blancs.
C'est quelque chose qu'on a très profondément inscrit en nous et je crois qu'il faut pouvoir le reconnaître et l'admettre
pour pouvoir lutter après plus efficacement contre le racisme qui est un phénomène structurel de nos sociétés et malheureusement aussi un phénomène structurant.
Donc ne pas le reconnaître, ce serait embrasser finalement l'universalisme français.
Je pense qu'il y a quelque chose de très beau-
Oui.
...dans l'universalisme français. Il y a quelque chose de-- c'est une très belle idée, au fond, l'idée que nous soyons tous égaux devant la loi ou devant la République, pour parler en termes français.
Et la France refuse effectivement de distinguer des différences entre ses citoyens. C'est une très belle idée qui est inscrite dans la devise républicaine.
L'idée qu'il n'y ait pas de Blancs, pas de Noirs, pas d'Arabes, pas de Juifs, mais qu'il n'y ait que des citoyens français égaux devant la loi et devant la République, c'est une très belle idée, mais c'est aussi un idéal.
Et le problème, c'est que dans la réalité,
n'importe qui a déjà fait la file dans une boîte de nuit, a déjà demandé une table au restaurant, a déjà passé un entretien d'embauche ou a déjà visité un appartement,
eh bien, tous ceux qui ont parlé à des videurs de boîte de nuit, à des agents immobiliers ou à des recruteurs,
ils savent bien que dans la réalité, il y a des Blancs, il y a des Noirs, il y a des Arabes et qu'il y a des discriminations qui s'appliquent en fonction de la catégorie de la population à laquelle on appartient.
Et donc aujourd'hui, on présente l'universalisme comme étant opposé de plein fouet à l'intersectionnalité. Je pense qu'en réalité, les deux ne sont pas si opposés que ça.
L'universalisme décrit une situation idéale, l'intersectionnalité décrit une réalité. Et il faut pouvoir, je pense, adresser la réalité en face si on veut parvenir ensuite à l'universalisme qui serait la situation idéale.
Pour revenir à la Belgique, donc, tu disais il y a un instant, on comportait tous en nous, finalement, ces idées reçues, ces peurs en lesquelles la xénophobie prend racine.
Je pense en particulier à la Flandre. On a pu constater ces dernières années que, voilà, dans l'actualité, je dirais qu'on entend régulièrement des choses comme
au Pukkelpop, on entend des chants racistes, de, je sais plus quoi, de Congo is violence, etc.
Il y a peu, il y avait cette actualité, je crois que c'était à la KUL, d'un cercle d'étudiants qui était trop loin dans-
Roeselare.
Voilà, c'est ça, trop loin dans, entre gros guillemets, son bizutage et qui va mener à la mort d'un étudiant. Et en enquêtant, on avait compris que cet étudiant se faisait appeler « nègre », etc.
par ses camarades, entre guillemets. Il y a également la proéminence de ce groupe dont fait partie Dries Van Langenhove, qui s'appelle Schild & Vrienden, la popularité écrasante du Vlaams Belang aux dernières élections.
Tout ça nous amène à penser que la xénophobie, si ça n'est pas un phénomène flamand, c'est un phénomène qui cartonne bien plus en Flandre que dans le sud du pays.
Est-ce que tu es d'accord avec cette observation et comment est-ce que tu expliquerais ça ?
Oui, c'est à l'évidence quelque chose qui prend davantage en Flandre
que dans la partie francophone du pays. Et je pense que ça s'explique largement parce qu'il y a en Flandre un véritable idéal de nation et qu'il y a quelque part en Flandre un lien très fort qui est fait entre le territoire
et la population qui l'habite.
Ce n'est pas pour rien que la Flandre a fusionné la Région et la Communauté flamande parce qu'ils voulaient créer une identité entre le territoire et la population.
En quelque sorte, ils voulaient recréer une sorte d'État-nation flamand, l'idée qu'une population soit affectée à un territoire particulier.
Et donc c'est bien sûr pour ça que la
xénophobie, je pense, prend davantage
en Flandre qu'elle ne peut prendre en Wallonie, parce que quelque part dans l'espace francophone du pays, grâce à Bruxelles, grâce aux communes à facilités, nous avons détaché la question de la population de celle du territoire.
Et je pense que ce détachement est quelque part très très important. Tandis que la Flandre vit toujours quelque part dans cette vieille idée qui date du traité de paix de Westphalie, au XVIIe siècle,
de l'idée qu'il y ait une coïncidence entre les frontières géographiques, les frontières démographiques et les frontières politiques.
Qu'à un territoire corresponde une population et corresponde une autorité politique, un gouvernement. Et donc c'est pour cela, je pense, qu'il y a un sentiment xénophobe plus fort en Flandre.
Au sens propre, il y a une peur que quelque part, l'arrivée d'étrangers ne perturbe cette juxtaposition, cette coïncidence des trois frontières géographiques, démographiques et politiques.
Mais ce n'est pas le cas uniquement en Flandre. C'est le cas dans d'autres régions d'Europe également, où effectivement, on va avoir ce sentiment national très fort.
Le fait est qu'en Wallonie, rares sont ceux qui se décriraient avant tout comme Wallons, comme élément premier de leur identité.
Et donc effectivement, tu as l'occasion, entre guillemets, d'affronter toutes les semaines Theo Francken, qui incarne bien cette xénophobie flamande, voilà, dans les médias.
Est-ce que c'est quelque chose que tu vois évoluer ou est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui semble bien ancré dans le patrimoine flamand ?
Je pense que c'est quelque chose qui est très ancré
Mh
dans le patrimoine flamand et que quelque part, la N-VA, au début, a construit une partie
de son succès et de sa distinction avec le Belang en quelque sorte,
reprenant les éléments de ce qui était toujours le Vlaams Blok à l'époque, en reprenant les éléments nationalistes de son programme et en essayant de s'affranchir des éléments xénophobes ou racistes.
Le problème étant que le naturel revient souvent au galop et qu'on voit aujourd'hui toute une série d'accointances et de porosité évidente entre la N-VA et le Vlaams Belang.
Et je pense que c'est très difficile aujourd'hui de développer un projet politique nationaliste qui ne soit pas aussi xénophobe.
Et donc c'est quelque chose qui, à mon sens, est profondément inscrit quelque part en Flandre, et c'est quelque chose avec lequel on doit pouvoir parler aussi d'une certaine manière.
Et je crois que c'est très important, en tout cas si on assume de rester dans un pays unitaire, de pouvoir parler avec cette partie de la Flandre qui va se reconnaître avant tout
comme nation flamande et qui va se dire au fond : « Qu'avons-nous à faire de nos voisins du Sud ? »
Mh. Ça, c'est dans la théorie. Dans la pratique, tu as déjà donc rencontré Theo Francken trois fois à ce stade
Oui
sur le plateau de LN24. Quel bilan est-ce que tu fais à ce stade après trois fois ? J'avais souvent l'impression que Theo Francken
jouait un petit peu sur, bon, déjà le fait qu'il n'est pas en territoire flamand ici, sur LN24.
Et donc, voilà, il ne maîtrise pas très bien le français. Il y a ce côté un peu mignon de : « J'ai un accent », de : « Je rigole un petit peu en me dépatouillant avec la langue.
» Et finalement, l'idée
de sa démarche en venant ici sur le plateau de LN24, c'est peut-être plutôt d'avoir l'air mignon, d'avoir l'air sympathique, de rendre ses idées plutôt sévères, de les rendre
mignonnes, sympas : « Hey, ça va de soi, tout le monde pense ça finalement », alors que sur Twitter, il est tout autre.
Mh.
Quel bilan tu fais, toi ?
Il est certain que Theo Francken cherche ici sur LN24 à se donner une image d'acceptabilité ou de respectabilité, voire même de grand démocrate parfaitement acceptable pour la population francophone.
Il est certain qu'il tient
ici, dans un média francophone, un autre discours que celui qu'il va pouvoir tenir auprès de son électorat, notamment auprès de la communauté qui le suit sur Twitter,
et que malheureusement, comme tous les hommes politiques aujourd'hui, ils vont de plus en plus segmenter leur discours en fonction de leur cible et en fonction de leur électorat potentiel,
et donc vont raconter des choses différentes à différents publics.
Et malheureusement, Theo Francken ne fait évidemment pas exception. Et la difficulté, évidemment, de ces débats ici, c'est qu'il va en profiter pour quelque part
dérouler le programme de la N-VA, et il va le faire de façon assez prudente.
C'est-à-dire qu'à aucun moment, il ne va y avoir un dérapage ou un propos qui puisse être assimilé à un propos d'extrême droite.
Et c'est certain que pour qui ne connaîtrait pas Theo Francken et qui verrait ce débat pour la première fois, Theo Francken apparaîtrait comme un aimable conservateur de la droite bourgeoise, disons.
Là où je pense qu'il est important de lui parler, c'est pour les électeurs de droite, y compris les électeurs de droite en Belgique francophone, qui sont séduits par les idées de Francken.
Et c'est à ces électeurs-là, je pense, qu'il est important de pouvoir parler en montrant où sont les faiblesses, malheureusement, et la faiblesse et la vanité, je crois, du projet nationaliste.
Et c'est pour ça que parfois, en regardant les débats, la gauche est un peu déconcertée. La gauche se dit : « Mais il faudrait sauter à la gorge de Francken, il faudrait le dépecer sur le plateau ».
Mais je pense que c'est important de comprendre que ce n'est pas à la gauche que je parle en débattant avec Theo Francken. Je sais bien que les électeurs de gauche ne sont jamais tentés par un vote nationaliste ou par un vote pour Francken.
Je parle aux électeurs de la droite conservatrice qui, parfois, seraient tentés par des projets nationalistes ou seraient tentés de basculer du côté des extrêmes.
Et c'est pour ça que c'est important, je pense, d'avoir un discours posé et rationnel avec des leaders nationalistes en disant : « Regardez, quelqu'un de gauche peut discuter de façon rationnelle avec des leaders nationalistes qui flirtent
avec l'extrême droite pour essayer précisément de pointer les faiblesses du raisonnement et de leur projet politique.
Si on leur saute à la gorge, ça veut dire qu'on perd ces électeurs et qu'on passe pour le gauchiste hargneux avec lequel il n'est plus possible de débattre.
Theo Francken est effectivement très très bien placé dans les sondages de personnalité, enfin en termes de popularité.
Il est une des personnalités politiques les plus populaires en Belgique francophone. Et c'est vrai aussi que l'électorat MR et l'électorat Écolo, en fait, ont une énorme intersection en termes de…
C'est le même public au niveau socioéconomique, en fait.
Donc il y a effectivement
C'est un public relativement aisé, relativement bourgeois.
Voilà. Donc il y a effectivement une conversion possible entre les deux. Et donc tu incarnes plutôt le mouvement écologiste.
Et on voit très bien d'ailleurs les sondages, les transferts d'électeurs qui existent entre le MR et Écolo.
Donc tout ça, c'est dans la théorie. Mais je répète ma question : dans la pratique, est-ce qu'après trois rencontres avec lui, tu estimes que c'est un succès ?
C'est un format qui fonctionne ?
Je trouve que pour le moment, et ça tient à la fois au format et aussi à moi, il faut pouvoir le reconnaître, je pense que ça lui donne encore trop la possibilité de dérouler le programme de la N-VA.
Et donc je trouve que pour le moment, ce n'est pas encore tout à fait satisfaisant. Je pense qu'il y a des aspects positifs, notamment, c'est les retours que j'ai des électeurs de droite qui disent : « Tiens,
merci de le confronter directement. Merci
de ce débat qui nous permet de mieux voir les positions.
» Mais par contre, je trouve qu'on n'est pas encore véritablement entré
au stade du débat fondamental sur les idées, sur les projets de société et qu'on est encore plus dans une logique où chacun va en quelque sorte dérouler son argumentaire, dérouler sa tribune,
mais ne va pas véritablement le confronter à l'autre.
Et donc ça tient à la fois, je pense, au fait qu'on découvre tous les deux le format. Ça tient aussi au format télévisuel qui est forcément un peu court, et un peu lapidaire.
Donc moi, je me suis dit que je ferai un bilan de cela après huit ou dix débats, après deux ou trois mois, et qu'on verrait si l'expérience est satisfaisante ou si elle ne l'est pas.
Pour le moment, je ne considère pas qu'elle soit encore pleinement satisfaisante, mais je pense qu'il y a un potentiel d'amélioration.
Très bien. On te souhaite une bonne continuation à ce niveau-là alors. Pour continuer sur la N-VA, il m'avait frappé, donc au cours de débats qui avaient pris place avant les dernières élections fédérales en 2019,
il y en avait notamment un qui avait opposé Bart De Wever à Jean-Marc Nollet.
Et il était assez évident que dès que le débat s'approchait des questions de migration, des questions écologiques, le président nationaliste flamand traitait ces sujets avec dédain, presque en rigolant.
Quand Jean-Marc Nollet approchait la question des réfugiés du climat, Bart De Wever rigolait comme si ça n'était même pas quelque chose de factuel, comme si c'était quelque chose de ridicule.
C'était d'ailleurs ton sujet de thèse de doctorat. Et ça me faisait un peu penser à la situation aux États-Unis où on voyait,
dans les États de la Bible Belt ou les États plutôt,
ce qu'on appelle avec mépris les flyover states, donc le centre des États-Unis,
où on voyait, par exemple, des gens mettre du gros pétrole bien sale dans leur voiture pour faire de la fumée noire dans leur pot d'échappement, parler avec mépris des questions de Green New Deal, et cetera.
Est-ce qu'il y a un lien entre droite conservatrice, mépris des questions liées à l'environnement et le virilarcat, la virilité, le fait d'être un homme bien dur, le fait d'être bien sévère ?
Est-ce que tu vois un lien entre ces trois choses ?
En tout cas, au moins entre deux d'entre elles. Je dirais que le fait de considérer l'environnement comme une question secondaire n'est pas le propre de la droite conservatrice. Au départ,
les questions d'environnement sont amenées par la droite conservatrice. Aux États-Unis, c'est par exemple les républicains qui font passer les lois environnementales les plus avancées, simplement parce que, à l'époque,
l'idée est de conserver l'environnement.
De la manière que les conservateurs se donnent pour objectif en matière sociale de conserver l'ordre établi, ils vont voir au début la conservation de l'environnement comme une sorte de prolongement de leur projet politique.
Et c'est la raison pour laquelle les préoccupations environnementales sont au départ des préoccupations de la droite conservatrice bourgeoise.
Et la gauche, à l'inverse, qui est une gauche très très industrielle, qui va essayer de porter le progrès social, va voir véritablement les questions environnementales comme des questions qui risquent d'handicaper
la marche pour le progrès social.
Et c'est la raison pour laquelle on va
Un plafond de verre, finalement.
Tout à fait. Et c'est la raison pour laquelle on va toujours trouver, notamment chez les communistes, des gens qui vont être encore climatosceptiques ou qui vont considérer que la protection de l'environnement est une entrave au progrès.
Et puis, il va y avoir le tournant du début des années 80, le tournant néolibéral
de la droite, où la droite conservatrice va devenir une droite néolibérale et où là, la protection de l'environnement
va être vue effectivement comme une entrave au commerce, au marché libre et sans concurrence,
et où quelque part, la gauche, à l'inverse, va redéfinir un peu ce qu'elle entend par progrès et va concevoir qu'il n'y a pas de progrès social véritable sans une protection effective de l'environnement.
Et donc, il va y avoir une sorte d'inversion.
Donc là, on parle de l'époque de Ronald Reagan.
On parle du tournant des années 80, du tournant Reagan, Thatcher.
C'est ça.
Alors, j'en viens à la question. Là, par contre, où il y a un lien très fort, c'est entre nationalisme et mépris de l'environnement ou plus globalement, mépris des questions globales.
Par nature, le projet politique d'un nationaliste s'arrête aux frontières de leur territoire.
Et donc, par nature, par essence, j'ai envie de dire, toutes les problématiques mondiales, globales, toutes les problématiques qui dépassent
les frontières du territoire sont considérées comme secondaires, anecdotiques, voire même parfois risibles par les nationalistes.
C'est pour ça que je dis souvent que
le plus grand obstacle à la protection du climat, ce n'est pas tant les énergies fossiles ou les intérêts économiques et financiers liés aux énergies fossiles, c'est le nationalisme qui empêche d'agir au-delà de ces frontières nationales.
Alors est-ce qu'il y a maintenant un lien entre un certain masculinisme et un dédain ou un mépris pour les questions environnementales ?
Pas spécialement. C'est vrai que les sondages montrent qu'en général, les femmes sont plus attentives aux questions d'environnement parce que les femmes sont simplement souvent plus attentives à la question de l'autre.
Mais je retrouve aussi ce dédain et ce mépris pour l'environnement chez beaucoup de femmes. C'est vrai qu'il est peut-être partagé par davantage d'hommes que de femmes, mais je ne le verrais pas comme une caractéristique strictement masculine.
D'accord. Finalement, quand on reparle de
questions d'immigration avec ces personnes-là, donc une droite dure conservatrice, par exemple Theo Francken, il y a une peur, donc une xénophobie dont on va parler, une peur qu'ils ne s'intègrent pas.
Qu'est-ce que c'est finalement l'intégration ? Qu'est-ce que c'est l'assimilation ?
Cette vision de l'intégration dans nos sociétés est toujours vécue comme une sorte de vision à sens unique. On le voit toujours comme un verbe réflexif, c'est-à-dire, on parle toujours de s'intégrer.
Les immigrés doivent s'intégrer, les étrangers doivent s'intégrer.
Et la question, c'est : a fortiori, dans un pays comme la Belgique qui compte des identités tout à fait multiples et qu'on ne peut pas décrire comme une nation, qu'est-ce que ça veut dire s'intégrer en Belgique ?
Est-ce que ça veut dire avoir une collection complète de Tintin et mettre de la mayonnaise sur ses frites ? Est-ce que ça veut dire participer activement à la vie du pays ?
Est-ce que ça veut dire avoir un travail ? Est-ce que ça veut dire parler une des langues nationales ? On n'a jamais vraiment défini, d'une part, ce que ça voulait dire.
Et surtout, on considère que c'est un truc à sens unique
et que quelque part, c'est comme si toute la charge de l'intégration reposait sur les épaules du nouvel arrivant et comme si la société d'accueil ne devait faire aucun effort pour essayer d'intégrer les nouveaux arrivants.
Et je pense qu'une question qu'on doit se poser, c'est : qu'est-ce que nous sommes prêts à faire en tant que société pour intégrer les nouveaux arrivants et pour qu'ils se sentent comme partie à part entière de la société ?
Et aujourd'hui, le fait est que
très profondément ancrée en nous se trouve l'idée que les immigrés ou les étrangers ne font pas vraiment partie de la société, sont des sortes d'autres, sont des sortes de eux par rapport à nous,
parce que le taux de discrimination reste assez sidéral, notamment le taux de discrimination sur le marché de l'emploi qui empêche véritablement les immigrés de,
de quelque part, de maximiser leur potentiel économique et leur contribution à l'économie du pays.
Et aussi parce que nous les voyons toujours comme un groupe à part. Nous parlons toujours des immigrés ou des étrangers au pluriel, comme s'il s'agissait d'un groupe constitué,
alors qu'en réalité, ça constitue simplement un élément administratif de leur situation, mais ça ne constitue pas toujours un élément de leur identité.
Et je pense que le défi pour nos sociétés en matière d'intégration,
c'est de ne plus parler des immigrés ou des étrangers ou des demandeurs d'asile ou même des musulmans au pluriel,
mais d'arriver à en parler au singulier, de reconnaître la personnalité de chacun d'entre eux et quelque part, de reconnaître ce que nous avons en commun avec chacun d'entre eux plutôt que ce qui nous différencie.
Et je pense qu'il faut pouvoir aussi admettre l'erreur que nous avons faite, chercheurs et une grande partie de la gauche, en insistant sans cesse sur la richesse des différences, de la diversité et en valorisant la diversité.
Nous sommes peut-être passés à côté, finalement, de ce que nous avons en commun. Et peut-être que le grand défi aujourd'hui
de l'intégration générale dans nos sociétés, c'est de reconnaître et valoriser davantage ce que nous avons en commun plutôt que ce qui nous différencie.
Je reviens sur ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure sur la vision utopique du chercheur versus le concret. Est-ce que ça existe concrètement quelque part dans le monde ?
Est-ce que c'est une vision qui a déjà été implémentée ?
Il y a des pays qui y arrivent mieux que d'autres.
Je dirais que des pays comme le Canada ou la Nouvelle-Zélande ont mis en place des vraies politiques proactives de lutte contre les discriminations, que n'ont pas encore mis en place des pays comme la Belgique ou la France.
Parce que parfois, nous sommes un peu paralysés par l'universalisme. On considère que puisque nous sommes officiellement tous égaux devant la loi, les discriminations ne peuvent pas exister, alors qu'on sait que c'est une réalité.
La France refuse, par exemple, des statistiques ethniques parce qu'elle refuse de reconnaître différentes catégories de citoyens, alors qu'on sait bien que dans la réalité, il y a de facto différentes catégories de citoyens.
Et donc, je pense qu'on vit encore quelque part dans une sorte de fantasme qui refuse de reconnaître ça.
Et nul pays n'a de politique parfaite en la matière, mais je dirais quand même que certains y arrivent mieux que d'autres et singulièrement mieux que nous.
En Belgique, Écolo et, 'fin, Écolo-Groen, globalement, fait un petit peu tâche d'huile en ce qui concerne sa politique migratoire, puisque c'est un petit peu
le seul groupe politique important qui se détache de, voilà, cette vision plutôt xénophobe que prône, par exemple, un Theo Francken.
Qu'est-ce qui explique que la posture de la gauche, que ce soit en Belgique ou en France, soit finalement si proche de la posture, ben, des nationalistes ?
Parce que, par exemple,
on a crié au scandale vis-à-vis des camps de réfugiés en Belgique, de l'enfermement des enfants
il y a quelques années sous le gouvernement de Charles Michel, mais ces camps avaient en fait été instaurés suite au décret, sous Elio Di Rupo, quatre ans avant.
Donc, qu'est-ce qui explique qu'en fait, il y a une proximité telle entre la politique migratoire de cette gauche socialiste et celle de, voilà, des nationalistes flamands ?
La gauche de gouvernement, c'est-à-dire la gauche sociale-démocrate en Europe,
mène globalement la même politique d'asile et d'immigration que la droite conservatrice ou même nationaliste, c'est-à-dire une politique strictement managériale qui va regarder uniquement les chiffres et qui va très fort déshumaniser les migrants.
Et le but de chaque gouvernement, qu'il soit de gauche ou de droite, ça va être globalement de rester dans les mêmes chiffres de l'asile, du taux de reconnaissance de réfugiés, d'expulsion que le gouvernement précédent, pour ne pas être accusé
d'être laxiste ou d'en faire trop sur le sujet.
Pourquoi est-ce que c'est comme ça ? Je pense parce que et la gauche et la droite considèrent l'immigration comme une forme d'anomalie, comme quelque chose qui, dans un monde idéal, ne devrait pas exister.
Les deux considèrent que dans un monde idéal, les migrations n'existeraient pas, chacun resterait chez soi. Et donc l'immigration reste considérée dans le débat politique
comme quelque chose de conjoncturel, comme un problème à résoudre ou comme une crise à gérer quand les chiffres sont plus importants que d'habitude.
Mais personne, véritablement, ne veut développer de projet politique autour de cela. On reste dans l'idée qu'il faut résister aux migrations et que c'est quelque part un problème conjoncturel.
Et donc gauche et droite vont développer des politiques différentes. Pour caricaturer un peu, la droite va dire qu'il faut construire des murs et fermer les frontières pour empêcher les gens de venir.
La gauche va dire qu'il faut déverser de l'aide au développement et faire la paix dans le monde pour empêcher les gens de partir, pour qu'il n'y ait aucune raison de partir.
Mais les deux, la gauche et la droite, restent fondamentalement prisonnières de ce que j'appelle le paradigme de l'immobilité, c'est-à-dire le refus de considérer l'immigration comme une transformation structurelle
de nos sociétés, comme quelque chose qu'il faut organiser plutôt que comme quelque chose auquel il faudrait résister.
Donc finalement, l'idée que cette immobilité, cette stagnation, le fait d'être sédentaire et bien attaché à la terre où on est né, c'est le monde d'avant.
Et quelque part, il y a quelque chose de culturellement assez tordu qui refuse d'accepter les migrations qui ont pourtant toujours existé à travers l'histoire de l'humanité, qui ont façonné et transformé des sociétés.
Qu'est-ce qui fait que nous refusons de les considérer comme une transformation structurelle ? Je me souviens, quand j'étais adolescent au collège, qu'on assistait à l'arrivée d'Internet au milieu des années 90.
Et on avait le sentiment qu'Internet allait tout changer dans nos vies. Et effectivement, Internet a tout changé dans nos vies.
La façon dont on communique, la façon dont on s'informe, la façon dont on achète, la façon dont on aime, la façon dont on s'écrit.
Tout a changé. Et au moment où Internet est arrivé, je me souviens qu'on avait des grands débats au collège. Est-ce qu'Internet est une chance pour la société ou un danger ?
On avait des grands débats Internet pour ou contre.
Tout simplement, oui.
Vingt-cinq ans après—
Oui
...il ne viendrait à l'idée de personne de faire des débats Internet pour ou contre.
Bien sûr, non.
Il ne viendrait à l'idée de personne d'essayer de dire : « Tiens, on va essayer de mieux maîtriser les flux de données sur Internet, de les juguler, de les contrôler.
» On a complètement intégré le fait qu'Internet était une transformation structurelle de nos sociétés et de tous les aspects de notre vie, qui apportait un
nombre incroyable d'opportunités, ne serait-ce que celle d'enregistrer ce podcast et de le faire écouter à des auditeurs.
Présentait aussi un certain nombre de risques en matière de fraude, en matière de fraude à l'identité, en matière de harcèlement, en matière
d'atteinte à la vie privée, et que le mieux que nous pouvions faire, c'était d'essayer d'organiser Internet pour essayer de maximiser les bénéfices et de limiter les risques.
Avec l'immigration, c'est comme si nous étions incapables de faire quelque part cette révolution culturelle. C'est comme si nous étions incapables de considérer que c'était une transformation structurelle de notre société.
C'est comme si nous étions prisonniers d'un logiciel qui voudrait résister aux migrations, tant à gauche qu'à droite. Et malheureusement, c'est une vaine entreprise.
Mmh. Alors, j'aimerais revenir sur deux choses que tu as dites. Tu as dit que c'était sur base des chiffres, que ce gouvernement essayait de se montrer comme responsable.
Donc, on essaie de maintenir le score du gouvernement précédent pour expliquer que finalement, on est dans la continuité, dans la stabilité.
Pourtant, ce que tu expliques dans le livre, c'est que justement, si on regarde les chiffres, l'immigration est plutôt bénéfique aux pays qui les accueillent.
Il y a donc un déficit de l'emploi un peu partout. On a besoin d'informaticiens, on a besoin de personnes pour construire les routes, pour construire les maisons.
Et donc l'immigration est une réponse à ça, mais on s'efforce à refuser malgré tout. Donc c'est finalement pas très rationnel, ce refus de l'immigration.
C'est pas rationnel du tout.
Oui, c'est ce que tu dis depuis une heure, en fait.
Dans ce domaine, c'est comme si la raison nous avait complètement quittés.
Oui.
C'est-à-dire, aujourd'hui, les politiques migratoires et les politiques d'asile sont absolument pas rationnelles et sont fondées uniquement sur de l'idéologie ou sur des sondages d'opinion.
L'exemple le plus frappant de ça, c'est que si on considère le pays européen où il y a le plus fort déficit démographique, c'est la Hongrie.
Si on considère le pays européen où il y a le plus fort déficit de main-d'œuvre, c'est la Hongrie. En Hongrie,
56 % des chefs d'entreprise déclarent qu'ils n'ont pas suffisamment de main-d'œuvre dans le pays et qu'ils doivent avoir recours à de la main-d'œuvre étrangère.
Et donc, si vous voulez avoir une approche rationnelle, utilitariste de la migration, on pourrait se dire : quel est le pays d'Europe qui a le plus besoin de migrants, et pour sa démographie et pour son économie ?
C'est la Hongrie. Et pourtant, quel est le pays d'Europe qui ne veut absolument pas accueillir de migrants ni de demandeurs d'asile ?
C'est aussi la Hongrie. Parce que ce qui tracasse les Hongrois, c'est pas tellement l'immigration des autres, c'est l'émigration des leurs, le fait que les jeunes Hongrois veulent partir, notamment en Europe occidentale.
Et donc on est ici sur des considérations strictement irrationnelles. Et là encore, je pense que c'est une erreur que nous avons faite, chercheurs, c'était d'essayer de déconstruire ce discours irrationnel avec des faits et des chiffres.
Et je pense que c'est très difficile d'opposer une sorte de vérité, entre guillemets, rationnelle—
À une perception qui, par nature, est irrationnelle et qu'il faut pouvoir entendre aussi cette irrationalité dans la manière dont les migrations sont perçues, qu'il faut pouvoir entendre ce que ça renvoie
à notre identité collective et que quelque part, les faits et les chiffres ne suffiront pas.
Il faut aussi pouvoir proposer un autre narratif sur les questions de migration et d'asile.
Plus loin que juste une question de politique managériale, en fait, ce que tu expliques dans le livre, c'est que
c'est le discours politique de la gauche européenne qui est décontaminé, qui est cantonné par l'extrême droite anti-immigratoire.
Je dirais que nous avons collectivement, et quand je dis nous, je place les chercheurs là-dedans aussi, nous avons accepté de raisonner avec les cadres de pensée de l'extrême droite.
Nous avons accepté de fournir des réponses aux questions qui sont posées par l'extrême droite. Et pour moi, il y a vraiment un point de basculement qui se situe en 1984,
lorsque le Front National en France remporte une victoire électorale importante aux élections européennes et quand Laurent Fabius, qui est le Premier ministre socialiste de l'époque,
dit cette phrase célèbre et dit,
« Le Front National, l'extrême droite,
pose les bonnes questions, mais apporte les mauvaises réponses.
» Et dès l'instant où l'on dit l'extrême droite pose les bonnes questions, on a une sorte de capitulation intellectuelle et politique en rase campagne.
Ça veut dire qu'on accepte de s'insérer dans les cadres de pensée fixés par l'extrême droite et d'utiliser bien souvent des concepts qu'elle amène dans le débat public.
Je suis frappé de voir comme toute une série de concepts vaseux qui ne reposent sur rien,
sinon des fantasmes et des idées préconçues,
je pense par exemple à la question de l'appel d'air ou à la question du grand remplacement qu'on a évoquée,
aujourd'hui, sont entrés dans le débat public et sont utilisés largement tant par la gauche que par la droite, sans qu'ils soient même remis en question.
Je prends la question du coût de l'immigration pour les finances publiques. Que n'a-t-on pas de sempiternel débat pour savoir si les migrants coûtent ou rapportent de l'argent ?
Imaginons qu'on ait ce débat avec d'autres catégories de la population. Imaginons qu'on se demande si les handicapés, par exemple, coûtent ou rapportent de l'argent.
On hurlerait au tollé, ça ferait scandale et à juste titre, mais pour les migrants, ça passe crème. C'est comme si quelque part, on ne les considérait pas comme une partie intégrante de la population.
Et ce qu'on rétorque à ce stade-là, c'est la fameuse phrase de : « La France ne peut pas accueillir toute la misère du monde » et que les migrants ne sont pas la responsabilité du Français qui paye ses impôts.
Cette phrase, elle est atroce. Cette idée, la France ne peut pas accueillir toute la misère du monde.
Ceux qui aiment bien Michel Rocard, généralement, disent oui, mais il a ajouté par la suite une deuxième partie qui disait que la France doit en prendre sa juste part.
D'abord, c'est pas tout à fait vrai. Et la citation originale, c'est bien : « La France ne peut pas accueillir toute la misère du monde.
» Et ce n'est que par la suite, notamment sous pression des associations, qu'il a rajouté la deuxième partie. Mais ce à quoi je veux m'attacher, c'est à cette idée de misère du monde.
Est-ce qu'on se rend compte de la violence de cette expression pour ceux qui sont arrivés, qui contribuent à la vie économique, politique et sociale de la France et qui se font sans cesse désigner comme étant la misère du monde ?
Alors qu'en réalité, la misère du monde, elle reste chez elle. La migration demande de tels niveaux d'investissement que ceux qui peuvent arriver, ce sont les plus privilégiés dans leur pays d'origine.
Une autre chose que tu as mentionnée, c'est le fait que la gauche tentait d'apporter comme réponse à l'immigration l'aide au développement.
Est-ce que c'est une bonne idée ? Est-ce que c'est une bonne réponse ?
Non, c'est une réponse catastrophique.
Très bien.
Et je veux pas dire par là, certainement pas qu'il faut réduire l'aide au développement. Au contraire, l'aide au développement reste aujourd'hui largement insuffisante, notamment par rapport aux objectifs que l'on s'était fixés.
Mais si le but de l'aide au développement, c'est d'être un instrument de contrôle et de réduction des migrations, ça ne pourra pas marcher.
Notamment parce qu'aujourd'hui, le principal obstacle aux migrations, c'est pas les frontières qui sont fermées, c'est le fait que les gens n'ont pas suffisamment accès à des ressources qui leur permettraient de migrer.
Migrer, ça coûte très très cher. Il faut payer de faux papiers, il faut payer des intermédiaires, il faut payer des passeurs parfois.
C'est pas du tout un processus de A à B, c'est un processus qui s'étale sur plusieurs mois ou plusieurs années. Et donc, pour les migrants, c'est un véritable investissement.
Aujourd'hui, seuls 3 % de la population mondiale a accès à la migration. Et donc ceux qui ont accès à la migration, ce sont souvent les couches les plus privilégiées de la population.
Le principal obstacle au projet migratoire, c'est l'argent.
C'est l'argent.
Ouais.
Et donc on va constater que lorsqu'un pays devient davantage développé, c'est-à-dire lorsque une classe moyenne se développe dans le pays, ça veut dire que davantage de gens ont accès à la migration.
Et tant qu'il subsistera un différentiel réel ou perçu entre le pays de départ et le pays de destination, les gens continueront à migrer.
Et on estime que c'est uniquement à partir d'un salaire qui tourne autour de 15 000 dollars par an que la propension à migrer descend.
Jusque-là, pour tout progrès du salaire, il y a également un progrès de la propension à migrer. En d'autres termes, si on pense qu'un pays plus développé va envoyer moins de migrants, on se fourre complètement le doigt dans l'œil.
C'est le contraire qui va se passer.
Et d'ailleurs, on le voit bien, les migrants qui sont en Belgique ne viennent pas des pays les plus pauvres d'Afrique, ils viennent des pays les plus développés en Afrique, notamment d'Afrique du Nord ou du Sénégal.
Et c'est ça, je pense, qui risquerait de porter un coup fatal à l'aide au développement. C'est si précisément, on la considère comme un instrument de régulation des migrations, il faut absolument séparer les deux agendas.
Et justement, est-ce que c'est quelque chose dont les acteurs politiques qui incarnent cette xénophobie, est-ce que c'est quelque chose dont ils ont conscience ?
Est-ce que c'est un projet qu'ils ont de réduire l'aide au développement pour cette raison ? Ils ont pas encore compris ?
Je dirais, c'est difficile de savoir. Je pense que beaucoup
ont compris, mais n'ont pas intérêt à le dire parce qu'il y a beaucoup de réalités en matière de migration qui vont quelque part à contre-courant de ce qu'on va appeler le bon sens populaire.
Et il y a des choses qui sont effectivement profondément contre-intuitives. Et un mensonge simple fonctionne toujours mieux qu'une vérité compliquée.
Et donc, beaucoup de politiques, même ceux qui ont compris, je pense, la complexité de ces rapports, ne vont pas s'aventurer à essayer de l'expliquer, de peur d'y perdre des plumes politiques.
Alors, je le mentionnais tout à l'heure, le sujet de ta thèse de doctorat il y a une quinzaine d'années, c'était justement les réfugiés du climat.
Est-ce que tu peux nous expliquer ce que c'est ?
Ce qu'on appelle réfugiés du climat ou réfugiés climatiques ou migrants climatiques, c'est l'ensemble des personnes qui sont déplacées de leur lieu de vie à cause de dégradations de l'environnement liées au changement climatique.
Et donc ça peut être à la fois des dégradations brutales, notamment des catastrophes naturelles, évidemment, comme des inondations ou des ouragans.
Ça peut être aussi des dégradations plus lentes et plus progressives, notamment la désertification ou la hausse du niveau des mers.
L'un dans l'autre, on estime que le changement climatique est devenu aujourd'hui un des premiers facteurs de migration et de déplacement de populations dans le monde.
Et le problème, c'est qu'on a volontiers tendance à le voir comme une sorte de troisième catégorie de migration, comme une sorte de catégorie émergente
qui s'ajouterait aux réfugiés politiques et aux migrants économiques, qui sont les deux grandes catégories de migration qui structurent aussi aujourd'hui le débat public.
Alors qu'en réalité, ces catégories servent bien davantage à justifier les politiques d'asile et de migration dans les pays européens qu'à décrire une réalité empirique.
Aujourd'hui, on a les facteurs de migration qui vont se mêler les uns aux autres, qui vont s'influencer mutuellement et les facteurs environnementaux vont faire partie de cette équation, vont faire partie de cette dynamique globale
et vont aussi avoir une influence profonde sur les facteurs politiques et économiques des migrations.
Mmh. Alors, tu as publié un op-ed il y a quelques semaines pour expliquer qu'on avait tort, justement, de mettre en avant les réfugiés du climat comme une raison de protéger l'environnement, si je ne me trompe pas.
Est-ce que tu peux nous expliquer ça ?
On assiste effectivement, notamment de la part de certains militants pour le climat, à une forme d'instrumentalisation
de la migration, avec un discours qui consiste à dire : « Vous devez réduire vos émissions de gaz à effet de serre parce que si vous ne le faites pas, il y aura demain des millions de migrants et de réfugiés climatiques qui vont débarquer en Europe.
» Et ce faisant, en réalité, on va quelque part agiter l'épouvantail de la xénophobie. On va jouer sur des peurs profondément xénophobes pour convaincre les gens de réduire leurs émissions de gaz à effet de serre.
Alors bien entendu, le but est noble et c'est une priorité qu'on doit avoir, la réduction des émissions de gaz à effet de serre, mais je pense pas que la fin justifie tous les moyens et qu'en instrumentalisant comme ça
les migrants et en jouant sur les peurs xénophobes, on va surtout arriver à ce que les gouvernements ferment davantage leurs frontières plutôt que de réduire leurs émissions.
Et donc c'est un discours qui, je pense, ne va pas du tout dans l'intérêt des migrants et qu'il faut le reconnaître pour un discours xénophobe.
En marge de ça, l'Observatoire Hugo, que tu diriges à l'Université de Liège, est en charge de superviser une série de laboratoires à travers l'Europe pour, aide-moi un petit peu, pour—
Coordonner un grand projet—
C'est ça
...européen, un grand projet de recherche européen qui s'appelle Habitable et qui est donc un projet Horizon 2020.
Pour ceux qui travaillent dans la recherche et qui nous écoutent et qui connaissent ce type de projets,
qui sont des projets en fait, qui mettent ensemble une série de laboratoires non seulement européens, mais aussi dans notre cas, des laboratoires africains et asiatiques, pour
essayer de comprendre, au-delà des grands chiffres qui sont souvent balancés dans le débat public avec deux cents millions de migrants ou deux cent cinquante millions de migrants,
pour essayer véritablement de comprendre ce qui décide les gens affectés par des dégradations de l'environnement, ce qui les décide à migrer.
Et donc, alors que jusqu'ici, la plupart étaient plutôt des projets qui essayaient d'aller projeter
des nombres, d'essayer de prévoir combien de personnes migreraient à l'avenir, nous, on va essayer de comprendre comment les gens vont migrer, ce qui va les décider.
Et par exemple, il y a des choses qu'on ne soupçonne pas. Par exemple, les gens vont souvent prendre leur décision de migrer sur la base de la manière dont ils vont percevoir les changements de leur environnement.
Or, parfois, les perceptions des changements de l'environnement sont très différentes
des observations. Ça veut dire que parfois, les gens vont avoir le sentiment qu'il pleut davantage alors qu'en fait, il a plu moins au cours des derniers mois, au cours des dernières années.
Et donc, ça pose de vraies questions. Est-ce que nos politiques d'adaptation et de prise en charge des migrations doivent s'appuyer sur les observations climatiques ou sur les perceptions qu'en ont les gens ?
Et comment est-ce qu'on peut faire pour que les gens aient une meilleure perception, qui soit davantage fondée sur les observations plutôt que sur leurs sentiments ?
OK. Donc en fait, on vient, pour expliquer aux auditeurs, on vient de se quitter le temps d'une heure puisque tu es parti en plateau, ici sur LN24 pour discuter du nouveau projet que la—
La Commission européenne l'a sorti aujourd'hui concernant donc la politique migratoire de l'Europe.
Est-ce que tu peux nous parler un petit peu de— c'est un projet ou c'est déjà, c'est déjà—
Non, c'est un projet. C'est-à-dire que c'est une proposition que fait la Commission européenne et qui va maintenant être discutée par les États membres.
Et j'imagine qu'il va encore susciter des tensions politiques et une nouvelle crise politique européenne et de nouveaux sommets extraordinaires de crise, et bla bla bla.
Comme toujours. Que dit ce projet ?
Ce projet dit qu'on va encore plus loin dans la logique qui est la logique de l'Union européenne depuis maintenant plus de vingt ans.
On va encore plus loin dans une logique de fermeture et de surveillance
des frontières extérieures. On va encore plus loin dans une logique de détricotage du droit d'asile, où on va simplement nier la possibilité à certains groupes, à certaines nationalités de demander effectivement le droit d'asile.
On va encore plus loin dans la logique des camps aux frontières de l'Union européenne. Et donc il y a quelque chose de vraiment ignoble
à avoir avancé l'annonce de ce plan après l'incendie du camp de Moria, comme si c'était une réponse à cet incendie pour que de tels drames n'arrivent plus.
Et en réalité, ce que ce plan
va réussir à faire, c'est simplement à créer toute une série de nouveaux camps aux frontières de l'Union européenne, dans lesquels on va parquer les demandeurs d'asile dans l'attente que leur dossier soit examiné
et dans lesquels on va réaliser ce qu'on appelle les procédures de screening, donc d'examen rapide et superficiel, de manière à déterminer
s'ils ont le droit ou non de demander l'asile.
Donc, on est vraiment dans une logique de fuite en avant. Comme on ne parvient pas à se mettre d'accord sur un projet commun en matière d'asile et d'immigration, la frontière et la fermeture des frontières va devenir le seul horizon politique.
Finalement, avant, on avait pour habitude de dire qu'il y avait vingt-sept politiques migratoires différentes au sein de l'Europe.
Maintenant, il n'y en a plus qu'une, mais elle est assez radicale et assez—
En tout cas, c'est
c'est l'ambition, mais en réalité, on va conserver vingt-sept
politiques d'asile puisqu'il n'y a pas du tout de proposition sur une agence européenne de l'asile, par exemple, pas du tout de proposition d'harmonisation des critères de l'asile.
Alors, la grande injustice, c'est que selon le pays où le demandeur d'asile va introduire sa demande, il pourra avoir plus ou moins de chances d'obtenir l'asile.
Et donc, en réalité,
on ne va rien changer. En écoutant les propositions de la Commission, on a l'impression d'entendre les boniments d'un vendeur de voitures d'occasion qui essaierait de faire passer pour neuve
une voiture qui est déjà en train de se déglinguer complètement
et qui a déjà des milliers de kilomètres au compteur, puisque ça fait vingt ans qu'on est dans cette logique
et on la poursuit malgré tout.
On a vraiment l'impression ici que la Commission a cédé aux intérêts de la Hongrie et plus globalement des pays qui ne voulaient pas du tout accueillir des demandeurs d'asile.
Mh. Donc la Hongrie, la Pologne.
La Tchéquie et la Slovaquie, essentiellement, mais aussi toute une série de pays du nord de l'Europe. Je voudrais pas qu'on mette uniquement ces quatre pays au banc des accusés.
Les pays du nord de l'Europe ne voulaient guère non plus accueillir. On peut pas dire que la Belgique a été un modèle en matière d'accueil des demandeurs d'asile.
La France non plus. Il n'y a guère dans cette crise des réfugiés que l'Allemagne et la Suède qui, quelque part, ont tiré leur épingle du jeu et ont eu une réponse à la hauteur de l'enjeu.
Quels autres changements au sein de ce projet de politique migratoire européenne ? J'ai cru comprendre également que, en ce qui concerne les bateaux de sauvetage pour
les personnes qui tentent de traverser la Méditerranée, ce sera désormais la seule charge des ONG, et qu'on leur laisse la seule responsabilité, alors qu'avant, on tentait presque de,
de leur mettre des bâtons dans les roues.
Maintenant, on enlève les bâtons dans les roues, mais on les laisse comme seules responsables de cette tâche.
C'est un peu le revers de la médaille. C'est-à-dire qu'on en était arrivé à une situation où on allait même maintenant criminaliser les opérations de sauvetage en Méditerranée.
On voyait toutes les ONG qui faisaient face à toute une série de problèmes, dont les bateaux étaient empêchés de partir.
Et on voyait des procès qui étaient menés contre ces ONG et notamment contre les capitaines de certains bateaux. On pense par exemple à Carola Rackete.
Là, on décide effectivement qu'on va décriminaliser le sauvetage en mer. Qu'on se rende compte de où on en est. On en est dans une situation où on va décriminaliser les actions de personnes qui tentent de sauver d'autres personnes de la noyade.
Il faut se rendre compte de l'état où on en est.
Mais aussi, le revers de la médaille, c'est que de ce fait,
les États européens vont quelque part se défausser de leur responsabilité de sauvetage sur le dos des ONG et ça va désormais être aux ONG d'assurer seules les opérations de sauvetage en mer.
Donc c'est positif, mais en même temps, un triste constat.
C'est un très triste constat.
Oui. Pour revenir donc à la question des camps. Donc actuellement, la situation pour les personnes qui tentent d'immigrer en Europe, c'est très souvent un entassement dans des camps.
Le camp de la Moria est un exemple tristement célèbre.
On est dans une logique, effectivement, où on va faire comme s'il s'agissait de parquer les gens à l'écart de la société, comme s'il s'agissait de
les identifier comme étant différents des membres de la société et donc de les isoler dans des sortes de non-lieux, littéralement, dans des sortes de zones sans droits où leurs droits ne seraient pas véritablement respectés, comme si quelque part, on ne voulait pas
les intégrer et comme s'il s'agissait quelque part d'invisibiliser le problème en espérant qu'il disparaisse de lui-même.
Mais le problème, c'est que ça ne va pas disparaître et qu'au contraire, ça risque bien, en laissant pourrir la situation, d'en arriver à des situations de détresse humanitaire comme celles qu'on a connues avec le camp de Moria.
On en est arrivé aujourd'hui dans une situation où les camps, qui sont en principe des lieux de passage, des lieux strictement temporaires, deviennent de plus en plus des lieux d'habitat permanent.
Donc on s'approche tout doucement de la fin de notre entretien ensemble, François. Ce que tu exprimes dans ton livre, c'est finalement une remise en question de toutes ces idées reçues, que ce soit l'appel d'air, que ce soit
le grand remplacement,
l'idée qu'il y a ce jugement de valeur par rapport aux personnes qui sont en mesure de,
d'immigrer vers l'Europe.
Et le but, c'est aussi de proposer, je dirais, au-delà de la déconstruction des idées reçues, c'est de proposer quelque part une autre manière de penser et de réfléchir à ces questions qui soit davantage apaisée et davantage pragmatique
et moins idéologique.
Et j'assume complètement un côté très pragmatique. Essayons de voir ce qui fonctionne, la manière dont les choses pourraient être mieux organisées.
Et qu'on se rende compte qu'en réalité, on se tire souvent une balle dans le pied par rapport au potentiel d'émigration,
simplement en ayant une approche strictement idéologique de la question, rythmée par des polémiques incessantes qui reviennent toujours dans la figure de gens qui n'ont rien demandé.
Donc tu proposes une autre solution. Tu as-
Je propose en tout cas une autre approche et de déconstruire les questions qui structurent le débat public sur ces questions, qu'il s'agisse du voile, qu'il s'agisse de la laïcité, qu'il s'agisse de leur contribution économique, qu'il s'agisse
de l'asile, qu'il s'agisse de la distinction entre réfugiés politiques ou migrants économiques.
J'essaye quelque part de ramener toutes ces questions à la réalité du terrain et de montrer
comment il y a une sorte de défaite généralisée des démocrates en ayant accepté les cadres de pensée et les codes de l'extrême droite pour penser ces sujets.
Et j'essaie de montrer qu'il est possible de les penser de façon à la fois progressiste et libérale.
Et cette approche autre, cette approche qui se démarque du status quo actuel, du discours actuel dans les médias. Un point de ton discours qui incarne bien cette approche autre, c'est que tu défends l'idée de l'ouverture totale des frontières.
Est-ce que tu peux nous parler un peu de ça ?
Oui, je pense effectivement que l'approche la plus rationnelle et la plus pragmatique aux défis des migrations au vingt-et-unième siècle, c'est l'ouverture des frontières.
Alors, je sais bien que ça hérisse le poil sans doute d'un grand nombre de personnes qui sont en train de nous écouter et qui se disent : « Mais qu'est-ce que c'est que cette folie si on commence à vouloir ouvrir les frontières ?
» Et je suis frappé de voir le nombre de politiques à qui j'en parle et qui me disent : « Vous savez, je suis un libéral et donc je suis absolument d'accord avec vous pour l'ouverture des frontières. »
Mais je ne peux pas le dire.
Vous savez bien que je ne peux pas le dire publiquement et que ma carrière politique serait fichue si jamais je le dis publiquement parce que l'opinion publique n'y est pas prête.
Et le problème, c'est que les gens s'imaginent toujours que l'ouverture des frontières,
ça signifie le chaos migratoire, ça signifie que tout le monde va venir, ça signifie qu'il va y avoir une sorte de déferlement de migrations venues d'Afrique ou d'Asie vers l'Europe et que finalement, on va être complètement submergé.
On voit bien que ça n'est pas le cas au Canada, par exemple.
D'une part, ce n'est absolument pas le cas et quelque part, l'histoire nous apprend que lorsqu'on a fermé les frontières, ça n'a pas forcément ralenti l'immigration.
Aujourd'hui, les frontières de l'Union européenne sont fermées comme jamais. Et pourtant, il y a un flux migratoire important et sans doute un des plus importants de l'histoire récente de l'Union européenne.
Et à l'inverse, dans des pays qui ont la frontière ouverte, par exemple entre l'Inde et le Népal, il n'y a pas d'un coup un exode massif des Népalais vers l'Inde, alors que ce sont deux pays avec des niveaux de développement très très différents.
Et sociologiquement, on sait aussi que les gens ne migrent pas parce qu'une frontière est ouverte ou ne s'arrêtent pas de migrer parce qu'une frontière est fermée.
Et je dirais que pour moi, effectivement, l'ouverture des frontières,
c'est la manière de reconnaître que la mobilité, la migration est à la fois un droit fondamental des gens qui est inscrit dans la Déclaration universelle des droits de l'Homme, dans l'article treize,
et qui est aussi une transformation structurelle de nos sociétés.
Le meilleur moyen, paradoxalement, de mieux organiser les migrations et de mieux contrôler les frontières,
c'est de les ouvrir. Ce qui provoque le chaos aux frontières, ce qui provoque des drames,
sans nom, ce qui provoque des morts aux frontières et ce qui provoque l'impossibilité de contrôler qui va et qui vient, c'est précisément une fermeture des frontières qui ne bénéficie qu'aux passeurs et qu'aux nationalistes et aux extrémistes.
On sait qu'on a tendance, en période de crise, que ça soit une crise sanitaire, économique ou migratoire, à se sentir davantage rassuré si les frontières sont fermées.
Et donc, les extrémistes ont parfaitement compris aujourd'hui tout l'intérêt qu'ils avaient à instaurer et à installer dans le débat public
une rhétorique et un imaginaire de crise migratoire pour convaincre les gens que face à cette crise, il faut fermer les frontières.
Et cette fermeture des frontières va générer et amplifier la crise. Et donc, on est véritablement dans un cercle vicieux, dans une sorte de serpent qui se mord la queue.
La crise engendre la fermeture des frontières qui elle-même engendre la crise. Il faut absolument sortir de ce cercle vicieux.
C'est magnifiquement résumé. C'est un magnifique mot de conclusion. Merci beaucoup, François.
Avec plaisir.
Pour ces Septante Minutes. Et on se retrouve dans deux semaines pour continuer la discussion au sujet du racisme avec Rokhaya Diallo.
Merci beaucoup. Au revoir.
Merci.
C'était un vrai plaisir de discuter de migration avec François pendant septante minutes. J'espère que ça vous a plu aussi.
J'ai hâte d'avoir vos retours. Comme on l'a expliqué, on a enregistré cet échange dans le bureau de la chaîne LN24. Pour l'anecdote, je suis arrivé là-bas en milieu de journée vers quinze heures trente et, on rentre là-bas comme dans un moulin.
On a d'ailleurs enregistré le podcast dans le bureau du directeur de la chaîne, Maxime Buxant, qui n'était pas là ce jour-là.
Si vous n'êtes pas encore abonné à Septante Minutes Avec, n'hésitez pas à vous abonner au podcast sur votre plateforme de podcast préférée et à suivre Septante Minutes Avec sur les réseaux sociaux.
Tous les liens sont en description.
Dans les semaines qui viennent, je recevrai comme promis
Rokhaya Diallo pour un épisode sur l'antiracisme et un peu plus loin dans le calendrier, je vais interviewer une gynécologue qui se spécialise sur les questions liées à l'endométriose, une maladie qui touche dix pour cent des femmes,
mais dont beaucoup de gens ignorent même qu'elle existe.
Je vous dis à très bientôt. Bye bye.